um I'm wondering man for you uh have you
thought about uh my boy jelly roll just
had a speech that went viral sh out to
jelly man oh thank you he was jelly was
one of the first DMs I looked at when um
I got nominated and um it just I've been
cheering for him all year yeah I I
literally been cheering for it's crazy
cuz people don't realize he kind of
comes from that like
white boy rap World well you know I'm a
southerner so you know little white
jelly roll all that yeah you don't it's
not yellow wolf my brother like yeah you
don't you don't miss it cuz we all from
the same place might have been a trailer
park might have been a project might
have been might have been just American
but it is man and it's like so I was
cheering for him and and we we share a
lot of similarities you know what I'm
saying we you guys each have very unique
paths to where you currently are yeah
when I heard his gram speech my sister
my sister sent it to me cuz she loves
him to death and she said she said she
said sounds like somebody I know get
your speech ready F yeah you gota have
that cuz it's funny so my co-host for my
radio show James Andre Jefferson Jr he's
like man you know he goes to a black
church every Sunday and he's like yeah
man they played jelly Roose speech at
church bro yeah I was like what yeah man
hey man God God God going to make a way
such a crazy like it's just so dope to
see somebody like that who's been like a
peer a friend and and just to have just
this whole like and if you ever have
known jelly you know he's always been
this guy who you're like man if people
just talk to you they'll love you they
gave you a chance so many people and
again congratulations jelly I love you I
love you I love your family man you and
your wife for bomb I'm happy for you I
look forward to 40 50 more years of you
just doing it dope um I
um my my my thing is man just give folks
a shot that my my thing is I didn't want
to die without you really having met
Michael and and give me a shot I knew
you hadn't listened to me cuz everything
you say you missing in rap I already am
I was already giving you dope you know
and it it I'm glad that you didn't and
you turn death here to me for as long as
you did because it gave me an
opportunity to find the discipline
through run the jewels of how to take
two and a half years to make Michael it
took me 10 years of being with run the
Jews to understand I am building a
community I'm not just talking to an
audience it took me 10 years to
understand now seven years because I
started about three years ago took me
seven years to understand now it's time
you know and I take it seriously and and
not seriously to the fact it ain't fun
right or you and your old lady can't get
blasted to it and go to the flame eat
some chicken wing see something drop but
I take it seriously in that I'm trying
to give you or know I've given you a
level of quality that you deserve as a
listener you know hip hop is looked at
is something that does not involve High
art and culture or if it does it doesn't
involve it from a workingclass stpoint
you know somehow in order to be of high
standard you have to be Collegiate or
you have to wear you know weird [__]
with weird [__] names you know I'm
wearing an ebbit field jacket and I feel
stylish as a [__] cuz this
[__] made in America and it's
about football and this is the good
jacket my grandpa put on when he wasn't
working you know and and that's that's
what that's what I'm that's what I'm
about I take pride in this [__] I take
pride in the fact of knowing that
whether it was Pony or Puma or Nike we
did that we created sneaker culture Nike
doesn't happen without hip hop in the
same capacity it just doesn't starter
starter doesn't happen without you name
you can literally name anything it
doesn't it doesn't happen so valaga I
take this [__] you know what I'm saying
like I I take it that seriously I love
this [__] dog I love this [__] to my
court I love the [__] with my bones this
ain't some [__] I'm doing on the way to
somewhere else you know you guys have
done such a great job of in a world in
which it feels like the business model
of being a rapper
is uh extremely hard if you're
especially in independent rapper right
like it ain't easy it's not easy because
if you're just looking at what a a
million streams pays you right it feels
like a almost like a hopeless climb up a
mountain in order to really make a
career or be able to just support your
yourself let alone your family right um
you guys have done such a good job over
the last 10 years of um monetizing the
brand right what are some things that
you're doing with
Michael whether it's V obviously the
tour was successful yeah um you know I
think always tell people like if you're
if you got a fan base and you're not and
you don't have a hard weight obviously
people are going to stream it but you
want them to buy the 12-in vinyl you
want them to buy a CD a tape man I'm not
going to pretend to be no Mastermind I I
follow I follow my brother currency man
shouts out to him spit man he's who's on
the album yeah him him and two chain
they on my dope boy record usually your
dope boy record you're hearing we sold
the most dope sometimes dope boys just
throw a dope barbecue and invite all the
other dope boys come out and you see
their cars you get motivated to do good
in school cuz your mama tell you they
did good in school that's why they got
it that's how our record hits me when I
the spaceship views so I got to figure
out shooting something of that but
spitter um I love the the relaxed ways
that him like him and and mus Mo like
cuz it's just he do what's genuinely him
I remember going down there when he had
the car shop you could go get your
breaks and and [__] around and be have a
30 minute combo with sp there you know
cagine getting your brakes done and
you're hanging out with C you know what
I'm saying like that's that's the kind
of [__] I'm into so I've just leaned
into the [__] that I I love and like my
wife and I built um in the swag shop
over the last 11 years I bought that
when I was recording rap music I sold my
5 Impala and bought the swag shop off
Craigslist the first swag shop and i'
I've been to that one y I've been to the
first one yeah yep that's on Ros Highway
we got one on edge we got one in State
Farm Arena we rolling out two to three
next year um you know I'm like I've had
it 11 it took us five to really kind of
figure out what we were doing I just
always wanted to have a barber shop it's
cool place I got I have to wait in line
but what we realize doing Co especially
when we closed moms were dming me like
don't close y'all shops y'all shops is
one of the places that I can bring my
boy I know he's in the company of good
men with Integrity I'm treated with
respect there was just and then they say
man we love when y'all do the little
t-shirt drops and stuff so we were like
man we going to have to be paying R
let's just press up some shirts and what
we realize is man you are a brand
operating as a barber shop yeah I mean I
I think I B I I got a new era yeah so we
got we got more New Era stuff coming we
got more t-shirts and stuff coming we
got more product everything cigarette
lighters as trayes cool stuff coming but
we're a barber shop and we've spent some
time figuring out what kind of shampoos
I like I hate to smell girly so it's not
like I'm using my girl stuff I hate the
the I don't want to smell like Old Spice
like my dad you know what I mean so we
developed um I got a shampoo conditioner
thing coming out I got some shaving
cream coming out beer balm I just got
some cool stuff that you can just buy
when you at the shop you can getting a
haircut so I'm excited about that to see
what that's going to do because I know
that as a man I don't like going into
the beauty supply stores as a guy when
my Jordans drop I might I might have no
problem paying $200 for the for the J
but I don't want to pay $150 for a
t-shirt what's your favorite J my
favorite Jay um um my favorite let me
give you my favorite all time Nik the 87
Air Max okay you got Air Maxes on now
you got what
those but yeah so that that's my
favorite Jay's I just whatever I'm
Jordan threes you like the threes I like
the four to me is the most all around
it's the three or four for me the three
is very uncomfortable but it's just such
a I probably like the silhouette of the
for to B yeah four is amazing man no
it's and then yeah you know you guys
just dropped your own Nike SBs yeah we
did we did man we did